Ryan
Gosling has received a Best Supporting
Actor nomination at the Oscars which
nobody watches and nobody watches 90% of
the movies that are even nominated at
the Oscars this year but we all saw
barbie some people hated Barbie like my
colleague down in Boer Ron because he
didn't understand the movie and some of
us who did understand the movie loved
Barbie because it's a conservative
Masterpiece Ryan Gosling for all of his
kenergy that was teaming out of him
maybe he had some of those little
nicotine pouches I don't know he gets
the nomination Margo Robbie who did a
great job in the movie gets snubbed for
best actress worse still Greta Gerwig
one of my favorite current directors and
I I watch very few movies so she you
know maybe she'll be the only director
I'll watch for a year or one of three
arguably the most conservative and
Christian director working in Hollywood
today at the Hollywood level and in that
depraved place gamorra by the Sea some
of us call it she got snubbed as well
for best director I think that's
outrageous